- [Instructor] What I have
listed here is several
of the derivative rules that
we've used in previous videos.
If these things look unfamiliar
to you I encourage you
to maybe to not watch this
video because in this video
we're going to think about
when do we apply these rules?
What strategies and can
we algebraically convert
expressions so that we
can use a simpler rule?
But this is a quick review,
this is of course the power
rule right over here, very
handy for taking derivatives
of X raised to some power.
It's also we can use that
with the derivative properties
of sums of derivatives or
differences of derivatives
to take derivatives of polynomials.
This right over here is the product rule.
If I have an expression that
I want to take the derivative
of and I can think of it as
the product of two functions,
well then the derivative is
going to be the derivative
of the first function times
the second function plus
the first function times the
derivative of the second.
Once again if this looks
completely unfamiliar to you
or you're a little shaky,
go watch the videos,
do the practice on the power
rule and the product rule,
or in this case the quotient rule.
And the quotient rule is
a little bit more involved
and we have practicing videos
on that and I always have
mixed feelings about it
because if you don't remember
the quotient rule, you can
usually or you can always convert
a quotient into a product
by expressing this thing
at the bottom as F of X times
G of X to the negative one.
So you could take the
derivative with a combination
of the products and this
fourth rule over here,
the chain rule.
And if any of this is looking
unfamiliar again don't watch
this video, this video is
for folks who are familiar
with each of these derivative
rules or derivative
techniques and now want to
think about well what are
strategies for deciding
when to apply which.
So let's do that.
Let's say that I have the
expression, let's say I'm
interested in taking the
derivative of X squared plus X
minus two over X minus one.
Which of these rules or
techniques would you use?
Well you might immediately
say hey look this looks like
a rational expression, I
could say this is my F of X
right over here, I could
say this is my G of X right
over here and I could
apply the quotient rule,
this looks like a quotient
of two expressions.
And you could do that and if
you do all the mathematics
correctly, you will
get the correct answer.
But in this case it's good
to just take a little time
to realize well can I
simplify this algebraically so
maybe I can do a little bit less work?
And if you look at it that
way, you might realize
wait what if I factored this
numerator I can factor it
as X plus two times X minus one.
And then I could cancel these
two characters out and I can
say hey you know what this
is going to be the same thing
as the derivative with
respect to X of X plus two.
Derivative with respect to X
of X plus two, which is much
much much much more straightforward
than trying to apply
the quotient rule.
Here you would just take
the derivative with respect
to X of X which is just going
to be one and the derivative
with respect to X of two
is just going to be zero
and so all of this is
going to simplify to one.
If we're taking the derivative
of that, you're essentially
just using the power rule.
And so once again just a
simple algebraic recognition
things become much more simple.
Let's do another example.
So let's say that you were to
see, or someone were to ask
you to take the derivative
with respect to X of,
let me see, so let's say
you had X squared plus two X
minus five over X.
So once again you might be
tempted to use the quotient
rule, this looks like the
quotient of two expressions.
But then you might realize
there's some algebraic
manipulations I could
do to make this simpler.
You could express this as a
product, you could say that
this is the same thing as,
and I'm just going to focus on
what's inside the parentheses
or inside the brackets,
this is the same thing as X
to the negative one times X
squared plus 2x minus five
and then you might want to
apply the product rule.
But there's even a better
simplification here.
You could just divide each of
these terms by X or one way
to think about it distribute
this one over X across
all the terms, X to the
negative one is the same thing
as one over X and if you do
that X squared divided by X
is going to be X.
2x divided by X is going to
be two and then negative five
divided by X, well you could
write that as negative five
over X or negative five
X to the negative one.
And now I'm taking the
derivative of this with respect
to X is much easier than
using either the quotient
or the power rule.
This is going to be, let's
see the derivative of that
is going to be one, derivative
of two is going to be zero
and here even though you
have a negative exponent,
it might look a little
intimidating, this is just taken
using the power rule.
So negative one times
negative five is positive five
X to the, if we take one
less than negative one we're
going to go the negative two power.
So once again making this
algebraic recognition simplified
things a good bit.
Let's do a few more examples
of just starting to recognize
when we might be able to
simplify things to do things
a little bit easier.
So let's say that someone said
hey you take the derivative
with respect to X and I'm using
X as our variable that we're
taking the derivative of
with respect to but obviously
this works for any
variables that we are using.
So let's say we're saying
square root of X over X squared.
Pause this video and think
about how would you approach
this if you want to take the
derivative with respect to X
of the square root of X over X squared.
Well once again you might
say this is a quotient of two
expressions, might try to
apply the quotient rule,
or you might recognize well
look this is the same thing,
let me just focus on what's
inside the brackets, you could
view this as X to the negative
two times the square root
of X and then you might
want to use the product rule
but you could simplify this even better.
You could say this is the same
thing as X to the negative
two times X to the one half
power and now just using our
exponent properties, negative
two plus one half is negative
three halves, so this is the
derivative X to the negative
three halves power.
And so here once again we
took something that we thought
we might have to use the
quotient rule or use the product
rule and now this just becomes
a straightforward using
the power rule.
So this is just going to be
equal to, so bring the negative
three halves out front,
negative three halves,
X to the negative three halves
minus one is negative five
halves power.
So once again just before you,
especially if you're about
to apply the quotient rule
and sometimes even the product
rule, just see is there an
algebraic simplification,
sometimes a trigonometric
simplification that you can make
that eases your job that
makes things less hairy?
As a general tip I can't say
this is going to be always
true but if you're taking some
type of exam and you're going
down some really hairy route
which the quotient rule
will often take you, it's a
good sign that hey take a pause
before trying to run
through all of that algebra
to apply the quotient
rule and see if you can
simplify things.
So let's give another example.
In this one there's not an
obvious way and it really
depends on what folks'
preferences are, but let's say you
want to take the derivative
with respect to X of one
over 2x to the negative five,
sorry, one over 2x minus five
I should say.
Well here you could immediately
apply the quotient rule here
the numerator you view that as F of X.
You could view this as the
same thing as the derivative
with respect to X.
Instead of 2x minus five, let
me do that in the blue color.
2x minus five to the negative one power.
In this situation, you would
use a combination of the power
rule and the chain rule.
You would say okay my G of X
is 2x minus five and F of G
of X is going to be this whole expression.
And so if you applied the
chain rule, this is going to be
the derivative of the
outside function, our F of X
with respect to the inside function.
The derivative of F of G of
X with respect to G of X.
So it's going to be negative,
we'll bring that negative
out front, so we're
essentially just going to use
the power rule here.
Negative 2x minus five to
the negative two and then we
multiply that times the
derivative of the inside function.
So the inside function's
derivative, the derivative
of 2x is two, the derivative
of negative five is zero
so it's going to be times two
and of course you can simplify
so it's a negative two
times all of this business.
Let me do one more example
here just to hit the point home
and once again there isn't a
must way, there isn't a way
that you have to do this,
but just let you appreciate
that there's multiple ways
to approach these types
of derivatives.
So let's say someone said
take the derivative of 2x
plus one squared.
Pause the video and think
about how you would do that.
Well one way to do it is
just to apply the chain rule
just like we just did.
So you could say alright here's
going to be the derivative
of the outside with respect to the inside.
So it's going to be two times
2x plus one to the first
power, taking one less than
that times the derivative
of the inside which is just
going to be two and so this
is going to be equal to
four times 2x plus one,
which is equal to, if we
want to distribute the four,
we could say it's 8x plus four.
That's a completely
legitimate way of doing it.
Now there are other ways of doing it.
You could expand out
to X plus one squared.
You could say hey this is the
same thing as the derivative
with respect to X of 2x squared
is going to be 4x squared
and then two times the product
of these terms is going
to be plus 4x plus one.
And now you would just
apply the power rule.
It's a little bit of extra
algebra up front but you can
just go straightforward with
the power rule and you're
going to get this exact same thing.
So the whole takeaway here is
pause look at your expression.
See if there's a way to
simplify it and it's especially
a good thing if you can get
out of using the quotient rule
'cause that sometimes is
just hard to know or remember
and even when you do remember
it, it can get quite hairy
quite fast.